so many people I talked to at that time
for all IPE they say this is the
stupidest idea you have ever got my
father he said this is an embarrassment
to me and was stumping all over me I
think every time I say I'm about to do
something people are waiting for me to
fumble I just can't live my life based
upon what other people think about
everybody told me do you don't need to
do that man some people would rather
kill your dream than see you succeed oh
you don't understand how hard it is to
make it Brendan it's so hard these days
everybody told me you're nuts you can't
do that you can't do that and the people
who are like offended by it it doesn't
matter
don't ever let somebody tell you you
can't do something people don't like it
so many people I talked to at that time
for all you pay they say this is the
stupidest idea you have ever got but I
think I don't wear the stupid club as
long as people use it now we have 800
million people using this a leap a that
must be the same bar by the building in
tensing hot yoga technique she came on
to be a young Sam Thomas in my sock get
honored ah monster I'm still a dick
neither the fountain Alton house this
way I getting it see average my father
he said this is an embarrassment to me
and was jumping all over me
I think every time I say I'm about to do
something people are waiting for me to
fumble that's probably one of the
biggest motivations behind a lot of my
raps is the amount of people that want
me to fall or whatever I think that
should be the motivation for most
rappers you know the further you climb
towards the top the more the more hands
you have on your pant leg dragging you
to the bottom they just start tugging at
you but
you know I wear really strong pants you
don't pay a lot attention to reviews and
those kind of things well you know
you're always affected by opinion but
the more opinions there are of you the
me the more I the less I look at them
because I just can't live my life based
upon what other people think about me
so I can't concern myself too much with
what other people think you know it's
just not healthy I don't think I can I
could continue to do what I do if I was
constantly worrying about what somebody
thought about it
well the biggest struggle man was just
getting around other people that would
say I could do it I mean that's the
biggest struggle just you get around one
guy says yeah you can do it and then you
talk to him tomorrow and he's like now
it is friggen he can't do this you know
there's so few people telling you to do
it you know what there is a lot of save
your money
protect yourself conserve don't spend
don't take risk taking risk is the new
way to be risk adverse so we're the
biggest struggle for me was my family
man the people closest to me was the
biggest struggle every time I went out
to do another deal everybody told me you
don't need to do that man the only
person that was encouraging me was my
twin brother because I would see how he
was doing it dude he was making his
swings and so every time I'd get around
other people so I'll tell you a little
trick I did on weekends I would always
go see Holmes I couldn't afford that has
always inspired me I would go look I
would go drive neighborhoods literally
I've done this my entire life until I
finally got to the point where they
wouldn't even let me in the neighborhood
there's neighborhoods in Miami do you
can't even go see you can they won't
even let you in the gates most of you
can get in if you know some of my tricks
so the point that your Vita is writing
on the board right now is you got fuel
in your tank
it wants to be accelerated on and then
you got somebody in the backseat saying
hey be careful nobody likes a backseat
driver okay so they're sitting there
they're putting they're putting mental
pressure on the brakes when you're
trying to accelerate I think I have an
insatiable appetite to make things and
share things with the world I have
you know I'm compelled beyond a
reasonable doubt to do what I do I don't
think that it can be a reasonable or
logical choice I think at a certain
point you're compelled to do it
it's too painful too brutal too neurotic
of a path to take otherwise sorry look
mike is making noise so I think that
that compulsion has to be there it has
to be something that you you can doubt
all the time but deep down inside you
know that this is something you have to
do and you know I think I've dealt with
some of the adversity some of the
challenges of which we've had many you
know I started a band and the world
laughed at me literally laughed at me
kicked us around talked about us in the
press for years and still do you know
but we hunkered down we worked and we
worked and we worked we play arenas all
over the world we have the most amazing
brilliant beautiful fans one could ever
ask for and we've had an incredible life
as a result so if I had listened to the
choir to the chorus of everyone I would
have stopped because that's what people
want you to do for some reason some
people would rather kill your dream than
see you succeed I don't know what that
is you know I mean I and RAM talks about
that as the looters you know we can
debate her in that some other time but
you know I think it's important to be
stubborn and to to follow your dreams no
matter what no matter where you are in
accomplishing your dreams or moving
towards the things that you really want
in life
never let your your small beginnings
make you small minded it's easy to say
well that's impossible and I know lots
of people are telling you that that's
impossible you know many people told me
what I'm doing today is impossible
Brendan you want to be a writer you
can't write better you you ought to be a
trainer you wanna be a speaker you wanna
do YouTube videos you're not good on
video you're not this you're not going
to this it's impossible oh you don't
understand how hard it is to make it
Brendan it's so hard these days the
stuff that people tell me and I know
told you is so nonsensical and based on
so many of their
own fears that have been unexplored that
it's sad and it can really cause great
people to stop trying to do great things
so I want to encourage you no matter
where you are believe in yourself
keep at it keep working keep going I
mean success and fulfillment are going
to come from your unflagging ability to
believe in what other people call
impossible it's going to come from your
unflagging ability to get up each day
and work towards things that maybe you
don't know where they're going maybe
they're not getting you what you want
writing it way maybe it's not easy maybe
it is a struggle but it is through that
struggle and that effort and that dream
and the desire that you get there I want
to do something I've never done before
and I don't know how but I can imagine
it
I want to engage in the unknown I
truthfully want to pursue the unknown
and in the pursuit of the unknown
something comes to realization and I'm
never prepared for it so when I set out
to do what I set out to do I set out to
do the impossible
everybody told me you're nuts you can't
do that you can't do that and that's
also consistent with all entrepreneurs
there's always a legion of people who
will tell them you can't do that and
even if you could why would you um
there's so many better things to do
other than that that you can make so
much more money from but money was
really a very very narrow part of what I
was really setting out to do don't ever
let somebody tell you you can't do
something
not even me
all right
you got a dream
you got to protect it
people can't do something themselves
they want to tell you you can do it
you want something go get it period when
this goes online or whatever it is it
really matters and it like really
doesn't matter what matters is you know
the people who are sparked by it and the
people who are like offended by it it
doesn't matter you you know like because
it's about motivating the doers and
anyone that wants to sit around and talk
they're doing too much time they've
taken too much time talking bit about it
instead of getting up off their ass and
following their dreams because I'm here
to follow my dreams you know and help
other people follow their dreams and
inspire people who are dreamers it's
crazy that we live in a world that if
you're super positive and super creative
that it's scary so what does that tell
you about the mentality of most people
if you're scared of like positivity and
creativity